such a fantastic film and and such an
important film to to to showcase what
really went on behind the scenes you
you've worked on other films where you
played real people um spotlight and the
founders specifically how did those
performances and getting ready for those
roles possibly help you in preparing for
worth
it does help because you
you have i mean
they're three really different people
from one another
um
[Music]
but you have to do the basics which
would be a little intrusive
but also for me anyway be respectful you
know
but not hold back you know
you
you pick the the
the
great parts of what they have to tell
you and the
less than great the dark parts of what
they have to tell you and so
at some point you
have to
be
a version of at least i do have to be a
version of them otherwise you're trying
to do an impression you can't really do
an impression you know
uh
they were both
boston region guys rob
robbie and ken
uh not ray kroc um so so it does help to
get in the groove of well how do you
what do you ask a real person or a
person who actually exists but you know
i've done it before to robert weiner uh
when i did live from baghdad so you know
i had to go over
he was living on a barge on the scent in
paris actually which was cool
so i remember had to go and hang out
with him for a while and uh
it's i find it kind of hard but
they all it helps you get in the groove
when you
do one of them you start to know how to
ask certain questions
i imagine you did a lot of research with
worth is there anything that really
surprised you to learn when you were
preparing for the role that you can
share
almost everything um
the answer is you think you know how
that you you think you understood
basically
the compensation fund really what i
learned was i knew there was a
compensation fund
after that it was
eye-opening to say the least
really complex